i joined almost three and a half years
ago actually almost four i guess in
September and the very first thing I did
was say that we were not going to spend
the pc division i don't know if you
remember that bad Assessor had said i
think we ought to spend pcs not printers
but just pcs and my very first decision
was to whether i thought that was a good
idea or not and i decided it was not a
good idea because i felt this company
needed to bed down get organized have
continuity of leadership get the right
strategy really invest in R&D and I look
back now and even if we had wanted to at
that time I'm not sure we could have
pulled off the separation so we embarked
on our five-year turnaround journey made
a lot of progress you know you've seen
our stock price you know our net debt on
the operating company was nearly 12
billion dollars today it's for 12
billion dollars of net debt now it's
almost five billion dollars of net cash
on the operating company so we've
repaired the balance sheet and I sent to
the word late last spring I said okay
how do we accelerate this turnaround the
markets are moving at lightning speed
and what can we do to be more responsive
to the market and frankly shape the
market and so after many many board
meetings a lot of discussion with the
senior leadership team we said it makes
sense to actually separate these two
companies so we can be more focused and
more agile and frankly have a capital
structure that is right for the markets
that these two companies will pursue I
mean as you said this is a historic
moment was it difficult to convince them
was it difficult to get certain
executives or the board on side it's a
journey that you go through you know you
surface the idea you talk about it you
run different scenarios you have another
meetings and the board was fantastic I
mean they did exactly what boards are
supposed to do they questioned they make
they asked for more data and it was a
very interactive process and we brought
everyone along together to the right
place on one extreme you know obviously
Michael Dell saw something and taking
dell private others said you could have
broken up the company even more did you
consider all of the possible
we concern we yeah we considered a lot
of different possibilities but decided
that we wanted to continue to be public
a public company because we wanted our
shareholders to get a chance to have
that shareholder value creation so you
might recall our stock price got as low
as eleven to twelve dollars and then we
built the company back up and our
shareholders and frankly our employees
got to share in that value creation and
so I think that that will happen again
here and at least over the longer term
and so we want people to be able to
participate in the creation of these two
new companies and and what we hope will
be the shareholder value